day two and round one of questions for
judge Brett Kavanaugh and a Supreme
Court confirmation hearing that gaveled
in at 9:30 this morning and continues at
this hour did you're looking live the
Supreme Court nominee facing some big
questions over Roe versus Wade executive
power can a president be subpoenaed
kehna president actually pardoned
himself chief legal correspondent and
anchor of fox news at night shannon
bream at her perch over the hearing room
joins us with the latest kid even
Shannon good evening Brett well today
the nominee finally got to talk
substance amidst numerous loud outbursts
once again and intense questioning about
what kind of justice he would actually
be I've watched his performance I've
watched his statements and honestly
they've been totally brilliant
president Trump raising his second
Supreme Court nominee Brett Kavanaugh as
the judge continues to run a gauntlet
marked by protesters
and senators still jousting over
document production I would ask the
Chairman if you might look at some of
these that are marked committee
confidential let me answer that for you
if you're interested in it you could
have been asking ever since August the
25th I believe today's question
centering on guns I never thought this
would happen in our country that someone
would bring a semi-automatic assault
weapon into a school and just mow down
children and staff and so I've been very
interested in your thinking on assault
weapons abortion I mean you just can't
what do you what are you doing for lunch
les overrule roe v wade and on his
evolution regarding whether a sitting
president should be subjected to
criminal and civil investigations while
in office as a member of ken starr's
team he advocated for aggressively
questioning then President Bill Clinton
and helped to write the Starr report
outlining the grounds for Clinton's
eventual impeachment years later he
authored a law review article
questioning the wisdom of subjecting
sitting presidents to invasive
investigations while noting Congress
holds the ultimate remedy impeachment
what changed was September 11th that's
what changed President Bush said this
will not happen again
and he was of single-minded focus every
morning for the next seven years for
President Bush was still September 12
2001 and it's Cavanaugh's time in the
Bush White House post 9/11 that sparked
numerous questions about whether he was
involved in crafting warrantless
surveillance programs or enhanced
interrogation policies and the legal
memos used to justify them
I was not read into that program not
involved in crafting that program nor
crafting the legal justifications for
that program also today spectators got a
glimpse of the human side of the nominee
who when asked how he'd like to be
remembered said as a good dad and judged
then paused husband
I think he's getting it good husband
thanks Dan
you helped him alive one of the few
light moments today Brett right now
judge Cavanaugh is undergoing
questioning with Senator dick Blumenthal
a former prosecutor a Democrat from
Connecticut it's been tough he said from
the beginning he wanted to begin his
questions by asking him whether or not
he'd recuse himself as a justice if a
civil or criminal issue involving the
president came before him Calvin I'll
repeatedly said I can't make that
commitment I can't weigh in on any
potential case that could come before me
Blumenthal finally moved on Brett you
should point out judge Cavanaugh gave
senator Feinstein a hat tip there at the
end of that soundbite Shannon thank you